I want to feel more like a man when I've
still got kind of the body of a boy I
want to be more attractive to women and
I want to be more confident all of these
things are the pure beautiful reasons
why guys start going to the gym I don't
understand why all men don't want to try
and improve their physique and the way
they look so much of what I have
achieved has come from my physique it's
crazy how many doors it's opened for me
but at the same time the confidence that
it gives you if you are unhappy about
your life or there something not going
right the easiest thing you can do is
just to at least try and sort out your
physical appearance and usually once you
sort that out good things start coming
after that bars set pretty low as well
if you do push P leg split three times a
week for a year you're probably in the
top 1% that's really all all you need I
think a lot of people they get confused
and they think oh in order to look like
that if I want to look better then I
have to go to the gym six times a week
and I have to start eating this boring
stuff every single day in reality you
don't need to do that it's just the
consistent efforts every single week
most people they go through periods
where everything's going good and then
it just stops